parliament has awarded the 34th sackarof
prize for freedom of thought to russian
opposition figure alexei navalny the
anti-corruption activist and fierce
defender of democracy is currently
jailed in russia his daughter collected
the award on his behalf
meps voted on proposals to end unfair
practices by big online platforms the
digital markets act aims to set new
rules to better protect consumers and
their data
companies that failed to comply would
risk being fined 20 percent of annual
global turnover
the eu is at least 60 years away from
achieving gender equality according to
the eu institute for gender equality
meps have demanded eu countries step up
measures to fight gender violence on and
offline as well as promote equal pay and
access to the job market
meps discussed tensions on the
russia-ukraine border observers say
about 100 000 russian troops are in the
area parliament is urging de-escalation
parliament debated proposals to end the
use of wild animals in circuses 23 eu
countries have already adopted a total
or partial ban
mep say the practice has no educational
value and puts animal welfare at risk